557 292 votes it was an overwhelming
majority with which European lawmakers
slammed the British government for their
lack of progress on brexit negotiations
they're fighting amongst themselves like
ferrets in a sack well the UK's national
interest however we define it is ignored
by them utterly shame on them it is not
good enough for Europe it's not good
enough for the UK either in its final
resolution the European Parliament's
declared sufficient progress has not yet
been made on major issues such as
citizens rights the Irish border and the
financial settlement a surprise for
lawmakers that the brexit ears didn't
believe the tiniest little bit in their
own propaganda and they were surprised
that they were so successful in fooling
the British people and unprepared as
they had they now are in the mess that
they created so in a way it's not a
surprise just last week UK prime
minister Theresa May appeared to have
broken the stalemate in negotiations
after signaling for the first time her
country is ready to settle the brexit
bill British parliamentarians say the
criticism is unfair isn't it you have
not given one iota it's all very well
holding 27 member states together in
terms of unity but quite frankly what we
see now is a facade and theater from the
Parliament in terms of the negotiations
they are not serious and the sooner this
country the United Kingdom leaves the
better well today's vote is not binding
it reflects the current mood in the EU
Parliament it's a body that will have to
approve any final deal between the block
and a little bit have to tell you this
good friday